-Welcome, welcome, welcome t
"The Tonight Show"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let me start by wishing everyone
a very happy Thanksgiving! Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
We made it through Thanksgiving,
and if your guests are
still over, just remind them
they shouldn't have been there
in the first place.
[ Laughter ]
This was a very different
Thanksgiving.
We all had to worry about
whether our lives were at stake.
In response, turkeys were like
"Aw, that must've been so hard
for you."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I spent the day watching a lot
of Thanksgiving stuff on TV.
There was the Macy's
Thanksgiving Day Parade
that we were in. That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"A Charlie Brown Thanksgiving.
And over on Netflix,
my new favorite --
"The Queen's Giblet."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, today was Thanksgiving
It was a big day for
that one serving tray
everyone owns that has the wor
"thankful" written on it.
[ Laughter ]
We had a small Thanksgivin
this year 'cause, in New York,
anything more than four people
Governor Cuomo shows up to
your house with a Taser.
[ Laughter ]
There were some things
I missed about
having my entire family over
like my aunt showing up
with a two-liter bottle
of Chardonnay.
[ Slurred ] "It's from
the register at Trader Joe's
It's good stuff."
[ Normal voice ] I also missed
when my uncle opens
his seventh beer and is like
"So, still telling
your little knock-knock joke
on the TV?!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
But I ended up having a nice
day, right up until my kid
said that they were
most thankful for Daddy
going back to the office.
[ Laughter ]
And this is interesting.
I read that because of
smaller gatherings this year
a lot of Americans also wanted
smaller turkeys.
When they heard that, all th
turkeys who went keto this month
were like, "Man, that really
backfired, huh?"
[ Laughter ]
That's right. Smaller turkey
were hard to find.
Today, pigeons
in New York were like,
"Why are you looking at me
like that?"
[ Laughter ]
It was fun cooking the turke
this year.
People checked
whether it was done
by using one of
those forehead thermometers.
[ Laughter ]
Then, just to be safe, they gave
the butt a quick nasal swab.
I mean, it's for fun. Come on.
[ Laughter ]
Some people tried to be safe
by eating outside.
However, it rained in
a lot of the country today
People were smart,
so they rented tents.
When it got windy,
they added walls,
and when they were finished,
they realized
they were eating inside.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, a lot of people
decided to celebrate over Zoom
and now it's clear
why nobody ever eats yam
six inches from a microphone
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, I saw that the TS
allowed some Thanksgiving food
to be brought through security
Yep, nothing better on a lon
flight than sitting next t
a guy with three Tupperwares
full of creamed onions.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
since today is Thanksgiving,
that means tomorrow
is Black Friday.
And I saw that,
because of the pandemic,
a lot of stores
are offering deals online.
Of course, if you want to ge
the full Black Friday
experience,
just punch yourself in the fac
before you click "add to cart.
Happy Thanksgiving, everyone
We have a great show for you
tonight! Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
His new book,
"Is This Anything?", is out now.
Jerry Seinfeld
is my guest tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Also, he was just nominated fo
two Grammys,
and he has a brand-new album
coming out
we're gonna talk about tonight
Bad Bunny is here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're talking to him, and he's
performing later on in the show.
It's a very, very exciting day
to do this.